こんちは！！　はじめしゃちょーです
今日の　よるごはんでございまーす
（拍手）
たまにはね、こういうのんびりね
ただ俺がね
よるごはんたべるものを紹介しよう．．．．．
なんてわけにはいかねーんだよ！！！
いや、いくけど．．．．
まあ、今日はそういうちょっとちんたらした動画じゃないっすよ
カレー屋さんのココイチ
全メニュー買ってきました！！
とりあえず全種類あります
うわっ　なす入ってる
最悪だ．．．．
はい、一応こちらが全メニューでございまーす
これね、ちゃんと店員さんに電話で全メニューくださいって言ったからね
入ってないのがあってもおれのせいじゃないよ
とりあえずふたを全部開けていきます
はい、というわけでこちらが全メニューになりまーす
ここらへんがまあフライ系、フライ系．．．
ぺちゃぺちゃぱちゃぺー（意味不明）
今日はね、ちょっとお前らマジねー
今日は、食べるからマジで
これぐらいはね　まあ　なんか　行けそうな感じすんじゃん　ね
うん。
今日はねマジ食うから
えっ、これどうすればいい？？
やっぱ、全部一回こうゆうのにしたほうが
やっぱみんな好きなんでしょ、？
はい。わかったよ
というわけで１回全部盛ります！！
というわけで一応盛れるだけ盛ったんですけど
たぶんこれぐらいが限界です
だいぶねー　もうカレーじゃないね
もうトッピングじゃないね
むしろカレーがトッピングみたいだよ
というわけでぜんぜんまだトッピング余ってるんですけど
ちょっと乗せれないんでもう食べます！
いただきます
んー　まずポテトサラドゥから食べま
うまい！！
最高にうまい！！
これねフライ系もねおいしいんすよ
んーーー
うまい
ココイチはトッピングがおいしいんだよね
これは何だトマトソースかな
んーー！！　ほんとにおいしいです！！
ありがとうございます
すごいチーズリゾットみたいなやつかな
うまい
いやマジお前ら安心しろ
今回は行けるから
すいませんでしたーー！！！(泣)
なんで俺いつも食えないんだよ．．．．．
≪号泣≫
なんでいつも．．．．(泣）
あもしもし　カレー食べに来てー
じゃあねー
≪号泣≫　　(嘘)
あーちょっと自己紹介していいよ
ああいいよ　あーええっとー
ついっす
不覚にもまた食べられなかった
俺はいつもそうだ
いつも一人で食べようと思って
結局食べられないっていうパターンが
ほぼ九割
おはし持ってきてあげる
ハクシューーーーン！！！！！！！
やばいっすねーー
あえて
カレー全メニュー食ってみたみたいな動画じゃなくて
カレー全メニュー食ってる時の会話みたいな動画出したら
この一部分だけ出して（笑）
これ新しくない？
新しい
本当に全部食べたのかっていう憶測が立つことから始まり
今もう終盤だけど実はすごいきついよ
みたいなことがみんなに伝わるから
（意味不明）
すっげークリエイティブな動画だと思うわけよ
こ、こ、ここオンエアすると
そう
で、全部食べ終わらないところで終わるっていう
あーーーーー
そういうの出したら
たぶんみんなは画期的過ぎて
ついてこれない
大爆笑
う、うえーー　（吐き掛ける）
すいません　ちょっと
ラストこれだけでなんで食えないんだって思うかもしれないんですけど
マジでもう限界です
申し訳ないです　本当に申し訳ないです
今日のお昼かな
そうだね
実は昨日の夜から始めて
朝にいたります
今時刻が朝の１０時とかなんすよ
というわけで
男二人でもまあ全メニューはかなりきついものがありました
ぜひ、みなさん
試さないでおきましょう
see you next time!!